brea california thank you for another
great show you guys are the best la
jolla california i'll be at the la jolla
comedy store august 5th through the 7th
philadelphia pennsylvania i'll be there
august 18th through the 20th austin
texas i will be there september 2nd
through the 3rd get your tickets for
those shows and all shows on my website
at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
please hit that subscribe on the youtube
that's the one thing i want to ask you
if you're watching and i know you are
and thank you for that hit subscribe all
right you can get a little notified a
little reminder and uh you'll get that
due right there every week for you if
you have to have more honeydew then
please subscribe to the patreon it's
called the honeydew of the all and i'm
highlighting the low lights with y'all
and y'all got the wildest [ __ ]
stories around there we've been at it
now for over two years
and uh it's one of my favorite things to
do i love my job and if you do have the
money and to sign up for a year then
you'll get over a month free you can
save yourself a little bit of bucks that
way all right
and you also get the honeydew a day
early ad free at no additional cost
again five bucks and if you or someone
you know has this story that has to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
the night pants nation tour continues uh
thank you guys for your support august
dates i'm at la jolla comedy store
august 5th through the 7th philadelphia
i'll be there august 18th through the
20th and austin i will be there labor
day weekend september 2nd through the
3rd get your tickets for those shows and
all shows on my website at
ryanstickler.com now you guys know we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers i'm very excited to
have
this guest back on the do y'all please
welcome back jessie may paluso welcome
back to the honeydew
hi
you're already laughing well i'm just i
don't know why but my brain when you
said dew for the first time i thought of
moisture
it's and not like the the melon that's
surrounding your head yeah i thought of
actual like dew
like morning dew yeah like morning do
when's the last time you went barefoot
in the morning dude goddammit i'm gonna
do it now i do it every morning almost
do you really yeah where do you walk
barefoot in the morning do in l.a in my
yard you have do i have to be chilly
enough to get dude you're flown in
out of alabama well hold on a second i
got to do i got to do farm down in
alabama let me get my dude guys
just do more to do
he just comes over it's like salt bae
but it's morning dew it dips down and
sprays it
look i got that dude i don't know what's
in it it's my dude a lot of chemicals
but i have morning yeah i put my feet in
it it's great to have you here again
thank you before we begin please plug
promote everything you'd like um i have
a fall tour with carly aquilino
promoting our podcast girl gyrl on
patreon and that's going to be all on
the east coast you can check out the
podcast you can join it's patreon
exclusive
and sharptong podcast is my podcast
i talk a lot of [ __ ] and have a lot of
doctors on to break down the brain and
divulge a lot of my personal life there
and um
i think that's about it i have a show
coming out on netflix but
can't say anything yet so another one
yeah yeah another one a good for you
yeah i'm excited
all right now you've come on and tackled
some topics uh our first episode we
talked about rape yeah we went right in
we weren't right we were writing with
rape we're like how do we
what's a lukewarm topic you want to
tiptoe into this yeah like tip top well
it's gonzo butt sex this thing i was
like okay let's fist toe
wasn't tiptoe
okay you did your dad's alzheimer's in
passing yeah and now i want to talk to
you about your mom because you lost your
mom as well i did now how close
uh did you lose both parents
my dad passed away in 2018.
and then my mother passed away in 2020.
so
too tight a year and a half two cloves
yeah you know if you want to spit you i
recommend spacing your grieving out
just for your skin's
ability to shine
because you're going to be dull you're
going to be dull for a while
you're not your outfits aren't going to
look right
you're not going to be making sentences
that make sense you're going to be
exhausted so you might want to space
that [ __ ] out just so that you can start
to look like a normal human being in
between but then again there's something
to say for when it rains it pours and
being able to sort of get
through everything at once
so
is was your mom's passing sudden like
were you mourning still your father
while your mom was slowly
um
i i don't know what i know because
nobody really knows what happened with
my mom um
hers was sudden
and i'm still mourning my dad
of course and so but it was still very
funny but that's what i'm saying
so it's not like you're mourning your
dad and your mom's passing from cancer
and you're watching her with her away
you're still mourning then you wake up
and all of a sudden like tell me about
the day yeah i mean this [ __ ] was my
morning partner
i was like okay well who am i gonna
board with now that's so rude and
selfish there's only one set of
footprints in the morning do
[ __ ] jesus
i was carrying
[Laughter]
instead of the sand it's the morning do
footprints
through the ground where were you when
you were on my shoulders [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was dying
i was creating a new size tens in the
sand you don't wear a tip mom had big
feet mom had big feet
tell me what happened you're mourning
your father obviously and then what it's
sudden so do you get a call are you
there i'm i'm still mourning my dad i
had just gotten a job with netflix
uh
covid
you know very very coveted tight bubble
shoot with netflix during 2020
and
this is my first job with netflix well
one of my first major jobs with netflix
and so i was very excited
and feeling like okay this is gonna be
this is a highlight in the darkness that
i've been enduring since
the dawn of time
just the highs and lows of my own life
but specifically off the heels of my
father's illness and him being sick and
dying this was like a
a bright spot a bright spot
and and it was also my birthday week
i'm sorry you always gonna you always
it's like that's a great sandwich
jasmine's like hey oh i got some pepper
bacon to throw on that [ __ ] like ah
you always throw you're like a 12-layer
dip over here
[Laughter]
it can't just be the middle of a [ __ ]
week when nothing's going on for you it
it just
oh i'm sorry it just can't be a regular
old wednesday or some [ __ ] for you it's
gotta be some some [ __ ] you'll remember
forever
[Laughter]
it in hours not an hour okay go ahead
so i was like
two days into filming
like my dream job
and i get the worst call who calls you
[Laughter]
two days into filming my dream job and i
get the worst call of my life like
seriously
um
it was
like
i want to say the september 17th the day
after my birthday and
my sister calls
and she says
that the doctor she said i met mom went
to the hospital and the doctor's asking
for a dnr
that's the call you get yeah like
just out of the blue
and i'm like [ __ ] i i don't know what
that acronym means
i don't know if it's a new rap group
but i don't like the sound of it
it sounds really bad i mean i knew what
it was but
um it was just so confusing
i was so confused
and
my mother was unresponsive
and
she was found that way no
so what had happened was
an amalgamation of
traumatic things to her body throughout
the years first of all she was a heavy
smoker
for a chunk of her life and through my
pregnancy hello thank you comedy really
oh yeah yeah and we say heavy do you
know like
i mean probably pack a day
at least a pack a day for a while for
you know a good chunk of her life so and
there was emphysema issues throughout
the years and she did have this sort of
um
audible wheeze to her
breathing
like you could hear her breathing and it
sounded
not my laugh yeah
is ryan zickler here
what the [ __ ] is he doing here on
thanksgiving
exactly it sounded like your laugh
um
and over the years she just breaks down
you know the thing about our bodies and
illnesses is so often the breakdown is
silent there aren't a lot of symptoms we
chop the symptoms up to
something else and we make excuses for
them instead of really like digging in
deep and seeing what where the bread
clump crumbs led to
and i think that that was definitely a
case with her so she had the emphysema
that was an issue and this breathing she
had a
um
what do you call those uh resp those
like little pumps that you use for
people with asthma yeah you know she
used that for years inhaler inhaler in
her
it's so
people get so used to the way things
are done in the way the life is being
lived that we really don't pay attention
to the signs we just adapt we're
creatures of habit we're creatures of
habit and we don't sometimes we don't
ask enough questions because the
questions disrupt
our comfort
and i think that
with my mom there was so many things
that
we're telling and also she's a grown-ass
woman we can't tell her how to live her
life
so there's a lot going on there's a lot
at stake and there's a lot that you're
battling to try to get through this [ __ ]
but her her pills in the morning
this [ __ ] looked like it looked like a a
candy jar
like there were so many different pills
that she had to go through each one yeah
it was like damn like are you dealing
what's the deal
what's going on she had a kaleidoscope
of colors of pills and half were
pharmaceutical half were you know
things that she was taking for you know
like your primrose oil and your fish oil
fish oil and all of that stuff your
magnesium but there was just a
cornucopia
of pills that she was taking daily that
we just accepted we accepted the
emphysema we accepted the pills because
that's what are you going to do
so many people deal with that their
parents and their loved ones they just
live the way they live and they're like
i don't want to hear when you like try
to offer up an alternative eh
i don't want to [ __ ] hear it so it
was years ago that death's like jesuit
moves out yeah and then the grim reaper
is hey
you're like uh i think i'm right here
would you like yeah grandmother's like
hey yeah
remember that that ryan sickler wheeze i
gave your mom for 10 years
[Music]
i'm the irs for your soul
um
so what ended up happening on that night
was my mother had
her stomach flipped
what's that mean um i've never heard
that it's a very rare thing and it's
like literally turned over inside it
actually flips that's right um and that
can be due to a lot of different things
it can be due to a lot of different
things stress is
one thing that can cause that but stress
is such a huge
cornerstone for a multitude of our
problems
and foundation it's a foundation
and sometimes with the body we've talked
about this before it sends off a paul
revere of sorts
to get you to focus on all the other
[ __ ] that's breaking down
so whatever manifests sometimes isn't
the main cause of the issues it's just
the alarm
and so i think that that was one issue
with her stomach was that was just an
alarm for the rest of the systems that
were shutting down her stomach flips
and that's a 50 50 shot you have to get
oh wow go into the hospital that's a
maybe you might make it maybe you won't
your body's like oh you're not gonna
listen well here i'm i'm tossing in an
audible
turn your stomach back literally [ __ ]
is that your [ __ ] did she say it was
painful oh yeah that's what she had to
go in because the pain is so
excruciating
it's it's unbearable i mean your core is
everything if you don't have a strong
core you have so many issues in your
body from a structural standpoint but if
your
gut is off think about when your gut is
just a little off it [ __ ] up everything
and so it makes you it debilitates you
she went to the hospital
and
they had to do surgery if you if that
happens you you have to like immediately
they're taking you right in yeah it's
life or death
so while she was in the er being prepped
and waiting for surgery my my stepfather
was with her at the time
she
has
she passes out she loses consciousness
and has like a heart attack whoa
and so
now you got a stomach backwards and a
heart attack going on in you yeah and
it's also like did you just drug
yourself for for the for the operation
was she like oh y'all y'all taking me
under don't worry all the pills this
morning
i got you
um she yeah she passed out she lost
consciousness and
we found out that there were heart
issues
she had
a lot of heart issues that she may not
have gone or that would not have gone to
get checked at all if the stomach thing
doesn't happen exactly the stomach was
the alarm to the heart yeah and the
heart revealed are the british
and they're coming yeah they're [ __ ]
coming and we're claiming this land
um
her heart had issues uh and so that and
so that
put her unconscious and put her into a
coma
man
yes and how old is she at this time 72
okay and so that's where the doctor
comes in and says well we've got this
life or death surgery we need to do
but she also just coma'd herself
so what are we doing here like is this
can they not do the surgery while she's
in a coma well she would need she would
have had to been under she would have
been put under for that surgery
so it's almost like what happened was
inevitable in a sense but also kind of
useful to the scenario maybe you know
this maybe you don't not useful because
she died but
pretty not useful
it's as useless
what's the worst case scenario yeah
because that's what happened okay so
it's not useful at all
[Laughter]
what were you gonna ask i was gonna ask
that if a person i imagine maybe i'm
wrong but if a person's in a coma and
they still need to operate
that person even if they can't yell out
i'm guessing they can probably still
feel that
you know there's been those
struggle with like i can't yell out and
then they're being just
open and you're like jesus christ i feel
everything you're doing you should have
a sub podcast called new nightmare fuel
with
[ __ ] that i'll never sleep
i'll never i enjoy what i do i don't
need to hear [ __ ] like that
yeah it um
the doctor just was like do we need a
dnr or not like what do you want to do
here
and my sister was like i don't know what
to do and you know my sister at this
point
she had already been the spearhead
dealing with all my father's medical
decisions
and
just getting over that and you know
being a mother and a probably still
getting mail from it and [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah having to you know go through this
again for her to be
you know the power of attorney and the
the medical proxy it's a lot that's a
lot that she had to endure but
so my sister gives me this call and says
basically we need to do we pull the plug
on mom or not and i'm like
without even trying the surgery
exactly like but only because we didn't
we were so confused it was it caught us
off guard we didn't know what was going
on imagine like your mom's healthy one
moment the next moment the hospital is
calling you like do we need a dnr on
your mother like what are we going to do
here
so how about you flip her stomach and
clean out her heart
and can we start there
he's such a guy
how about we flip out our stomachs
why don't you just suck out the arteries
turn the stomach over suck out the
arteries man let's go stomach cleaner
machine
you all got the aorta pump okay i'm
gonna get my oil changed while we wait
it's all detailed out of the hospital
the parking lot i'm gonna run that while
y'all do that they should do they should
have a heart cardiologist heart surgeon
next to you
detail on the side i got a jiffy lube
we keep your valves clean
all your valves pumping at aorta
smart doctors you can take that one you
guys can have that just give us a little
bit okay so mom is not in a good way i'm
responsive
and my sister's like we don't you know
they're gonna do the surgery because
she's under they and they also had put
her under as well okay i assisted with
what had happened with her
um
and then my sister's like we got double
[ __ ]
uh anesthesia going on yeah it's like
yeah it's a triple because there's a
coma too her [ __ ] the medical [ __ ] and
the comb yeah she's way too [ __ ]
she's just like
way on the couch exploding like what's
everybody complaining about hovering
over herself look at that like oh it's
the best [ __ ] right here
um
and they do the surgery well
the surgery
revealed
all the issues that were underlying
and
for the entirety of her hospital
visit which was 86 days i think jeez she
was in the ic emergency and then the icu
for like 86 days it was a roller coaster
it was them just plugging holes in her
system
was it she in a coma the whole time no
she was not
um so you're able to talk to her see her
yeah like the next day
i tell the production what's going on
and i was like i know we just started
filming
but this is what i'm facing
and
you know they're like you do what you
need to do
this is this is so much more important
not that before quarantine and covid
that
studios were cold but it's just a
different world now where people
understand that
the human aspect of everything is taking
precedent without question so luckily
even though i felt bad because i wanted
to be there to do my job i also was like
i can't go through this again like
how is this [ __ ] happening again
so soon
um
so i um
i fly home
and i remember just seeing her
in the er
and what she said to me has stuck with
me because it's true even through the
hardest [ __ ] that you go through what
she said to me was because i i hugged
her like a baby
and i'm bigger than her
you know
she's a little thing she's so tiny she's
like
you know she was
i don't know what she is now i don't
know what a ghost weighs
that's a great question
because a cloud probably weighs
as vapor
we could just ball it off and set it on
a scale
isn't it is it a ghost just a human face
vapor you gotta have some kind of weight
that's a human especially if you feel it
yeah
i'll tell you i got surrounded by a
cloud once and i felt it
i feel fog
around me yeah have you been entered by
a ghost you feel that girth
um
i hugged her like a baby i i went down
and she had all these wires and she was
connected
by every
which way
and had an oxygen mask and and all of
that and i just put my head to her chest
and and she said
she said it's okay baby girl she said i
love you
and
everything's gonna be okay
we're always gonna be okay
and she's right
even when
you're going through the hardest
[ __ ] it's hard to think that way
but it always ends up that way
if you allow it to
and i stayed with her for a few days and
that ended up being the only time during
her
at least my experience of going back and
forth that was the only time during her
entirety
in that
visit
visit you don't really visit the er i
mean if you visit the yard you're a
lucky [ __ ] yeah this ain't
sandals sandals
it's not the maldot the maldives
the icu business icu no [ __ ] i
was institutionalized
by the devil himself no she it was the
most lucid she was in that moment when i
got there with her
and from that point on it was just a
deterioration
it was just
plugging holes because
her her lung
her lungs half half of her lungs were
destroyed from smoking and emphysema she
only had like
i think less than half of one of her
lungs that were healthy oh wow
she's breathing off and running off of a
wall it's a quarter year long yeah right
jesus and that's the other thing like
you're
whoo it hurts my chest literally
it's amazing when i was talking about
before what people put up with and what
we get so used to when it comes to your
own
bodies what we deem is normal
unless we're really awoke to our own
system into our own being
may be
a very unhealthy system that we are
and have normalized
you know we always talk about the
outside world and how we're normalizing
this in society the problem with that is
most people haven't figured out what the
barometric pressure is within themselves
we've got so much that's
traumatizing our internal systems that
we're not even [ __ ] paying attention
to
and that was what was going on with my
mom she just had so many things breaking
down that that the stomach flip was just
the the [ __ ] last attempt of her body
to be like we gotta fix this
and that's what they tried to do
they tried to fix her
it was like humpty dumpty that that's
just procedure after procedure the whole
time she's in there [ __ ] procedure
and it was like almost
those few months
were almost the same
experience we had with our father as far
as us just being like do whatever needs
to
fix whatever needs to be fixed in the
sense that the end
game was always going to be the same
because with alzheimer's there's no cure
right now
and with her she was so
her systems were so shunted by
everything that there was there was no
way out
we didn't know but there was there was
no
way she was going to come around my
sister
tried to tell me and i'm such like
i call myself an eternal optimist
i've been that way since i was a little
girl
and
it could be
not a defense mechanism but a coping
mechanism
but it's gotten me through everything
and not that safe not to say like it's
not important
it is important to acknowledge
the other side the jekyll and hyde
emotions you have to acknowledge all of
them they all need stage time in order
for you to heal
but perseverance and ambition takes a
lot
and you have to have your own fuel to
get you through that [ __ ]
and so i was just
[ __ ]
so optimistic
her lung was like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
come on man her stomach turned over
[Applause]
i brought krispy kreme to the hospital
[Laughter]
it wasn't it was it was glazed and
confused my syracuse shutout
of course you did that's what i'm saying
that's who you are in life you put that
kind of [ __ ]
you put that kind of [ __ ] into it i know
who you are oh my god
but i would agree i would agree it's a
coping mechanism you know wanting
everything as long as things are as long
as it's good and i'm telling myself it's
good it's good yeah exactly but it's
about to be bad all right and when they
tell me then what we can deal with but
right now
who wants some glazed doughnuts y'all
that's what it came with it wasn't
it
i'm with you on this my mom's in her
fourth coleman
jellyfish
my mom's lungs are filled with more
jelly than the donuts
okay
that one good lungs got a cigarette over
there
that's one little piece
he's just like man
man i'm today i'm glad i did stick
around you brought donuts man i love you
i love it
i love that your image of my mom's long
and sometimes
yeah yeah he's just the whole guy
smoking off just some like war veteran
yep
pissed off and bitching about everything
yeah excuse clint eastwood
from gran torino that's it get off my
lawn that's my mom's
this summer coors light is the official
beer of everything unofficial
celebrating those moments that truly
make summer chill the first day of
summer is june 21st unofficially
it's whenever it's warm enough to enjoy
a beer on the patio the weekend is
saturday and sunday unofficially it's
friday afternoon too you know coors
light's my favorite beer i was at the
roxy last night went to see my man prof
drank my coors light all night long
responsibly y'all and there's only one
beer out there that's literally made to
chill and that is coors light the
mountains on the bottles and cans even
turn blue when your beer is cold that
way you always know when it's time to
chill summer chill starts with coors
light make the most of your summer with
the chance to win exclusive chill merch
fun local experiences even a trip to new
york chicago or los angeles enter to win
at coorslight.com
honeydew no purchase necessary
sweepstakes ends eight fifteen twenty
two game ends nine six twenty two fifty
us slash dc 21 plus only voiware
prohibited for rules visit
coorslightsummer.com coors brewing
company golden colorado celebrate
responsibly take action today for a
healthier tomorrow with everly well
their at-home lab tests and vitamins and
supplements can help you get the
knowledge and support you need so you
can become a healthier you everly well
is digital healthcare designed for you
all at an affordable and transparent
price with over 30 at-home lab tests
you'll be able to choose the test that
makes the most sense for you to get the
answers you need everly well also has
high quality vitamins and supplements to
support your overall health including
vitamin d3 and omega-3 fish oil here's
how it works everlywell ships products
straight to you with everything needed
in one package simply collect your
sample and use the included prepaid
shipping label to mail your test back to
a certified lab your physician reviewed
results get sent to your phone or your
device in just days all right you can
even share the results with your primary
care physician it's so simple over 1
million people have trusted every well
to support their health and wellness
goals and you should too look i took my
test i took for um
um gosh what was it food allergies and
got back my results and shared i love
that you can share it with your doctor i
think that's huge so for listeners of
this show everly well is offering a
special discount of 20 off an at-home
lab test at
everlywell.com honeydew that's
everlywell.com honeydew for 20 off your
next at-home lab test everywell.com
honeydew all men strive for gold in
their life right gold medals gold
watches gold everything however there's
a certain type of man who goes the extra
mile manscaped would like to introduce
you to their best and biggest ultimate
hygiene bundle yet the platinum package
4.0 manscape is the leader in below the
waist grooming now trust them with the
whole shebang join the 4 million men
worldwide who trust manscape by going to
manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code honeydew
manscape's brand new platinum package
4.0 is the biggest bundle they've
offered giving you a bulk discount on
manscape's top products the manscape
platinum package 4.0 is the one-stop
shop for the man who deserves it all
they designed this package to allow you
to fully align your entire hygiene
routine with elite products get 20 off
and free shipping with the code honeydew
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use code
honeydew it's time you enjoy the finer
things in life and get yourself a
platinum package for your platinum
package now let's get back to the do
oh my god oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
it was okay it was a you know i had to
go back and i had to go back and forth
so were you date were you seeing her
daily
no because i had to go back i went back
to set okay because it was a closed set
so we did a uh and where was uh netflix
what state you said you had california
all right so what's up and i had to go
back to new york damn so you got a long
flight yes okay and you're going to
upstate yeah you say syracuse yeah
syracuse and that's not easy to get to
you know you need a horse and carriage
from the airport it's not like there's a
direct situation
um
so i went and visited her once during
the filming we had a tight filming
schedule
and then i went home right after
and um
tried to
you know be there however i could but i
also had to go back and forth
from la to syracuse again and i did that
i think three or four times
um the problem was i had planned to
drive
home for the holiday or for the
yeah actually for the holidays because
this was in september
so
i just ended up driving sooner
so i went back and forth a couple times
and then my sister gave me a call once
and she was just beside herself
rightfully so because this is a second
parent that she's having to spearhead a
medical
a very complicated medical procedure you
know and
medical
things that are being done to her my
sister had to like handle so she's
lost her [ __ ] and she's just like i need
you to get
i need you to [ __ ] come home
you've got to get here
and
that i flew back for that we had to make
decisions like well you know we had to
make decisions about
if if we if she should have a procedure
done because is it even worth it
there's so much damage to her do we even
do this procedure
and in my mind you know i was talking
about being like the eternal optimist my
sister's being the realist like
do we want to put her through this again
and in my mind i'm like yeah
i want to [ __ ] do whatever it takes
but there's some selfishness of course
yes
there's some real selfishness to that
and you have to really like as a human
being
ask yourself where that line is and
where you stand on either side of that
who's it for
that's i i look at it like listen i'm
with you i i'm like frankenstein this
[ __ ] put but also
you guys got a power cord
you might got a [ __ ] extension cord
get my stomach flipper we're going in
look
a little spatula a big ass like pancake
spatula
i think the
the real barometer is quality of life
for the individual we're all
we all love and want to save with
everything we can but also
is that person just going to be laying
there you know
dead yeah machine alive by a machine
only then what what the [ __ ] is that
what kind of life is that for that
person yes
yeah and you know and then you're also
having to
be at the mercy of doctors and i think
doctors and nurses specifically
i just applaud them nurses specifically
what they do and how hard they work and
the multitude of jobs and tasks and the
[ __ ] they put up with literal [ __ ] they
see people at their worst the sickest
they're most in pain yeah yeah they're
desperate long hours away from their
family i i really applaud them and i i
saw them in a different light through
both of my parents read fully agreed but
on the other side of that when it comes
to doctors is i also think there's this
sort of
oblivion and maybe laziness we have
where we just go okay and we just accept
what's told to us i never do that's
probably why i became a comedian i don't
accept it i don't accept what you're
telling me i'm always going to question
you as you should i mean in life you
should do that it's just it's just how i
am
and so
you know there was a real
sometimes we're butting heads because of
that where i'm like no i'm i'm not
accepting i want more i want something
different i want you know a different
outcome i was like
i was really battling
and not i was in complete denial
really just of what the
reality was before me because i wasn't
ready not that you're ever [ __ ] ready
for that [ __ ] but [ __ ]
i was like yo can i get a break
bro
i got [ __ ] my dad dying quarantine
hits you and justin martindale are
[ __ ] hanging out with brad pitt
the [ __ ] is ridiculous
giannis is best friends with stamos what
when am i gonna get a break and a friend
it's coming
it's coming
brad pitt's gonna be coming soon i feel
it for you [ __ ] you okay you've been
working it though you've been putting it
out there in the universe you're the
first one to hit me like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ]
like did you do this on purpose
did you do this to me on purpose
okay so you're not ready of course
you're not no you're never ready
are you there when your mom passes oh no
and was it in the hospital did she ever
get out of the hospital she never got
out and the thing that sucked was
because of quarantine and covid only one
person could go
and
there's so many
reasons to allow yourself to get furious
over the past
but you gotta [ __ ] let all those out
you can't even let them in the house
you can't let those reasons to make you
furious about the past in the [ __ ]
house because they won't leave and
they'll kick their shoes off and they'll
put their dirty ass feet on your on your
coffee table and ask for food and
they'll never [ __ ] leave
so i have had moments where i've had to
really check myself over that
mentality of just looking backwards and
being like well we could have done this
we could have done that we could have
done that
and you know what the answer always is i
think when we look back in the past that
we wish we could have changed time
how we spent it who we spent it with and
wanting more of it
i mean in hindsight i say all the time i
was 16 when my father died but boy
would i go back i would do anything to
go back when he said hey you want to run
up to target real quick with me and i'd
be like playing my video game nah yep
and now i'd be like [ __ ] yeah yep you
know what i mean of course but but also
you can kill yourself doing that you
could kill yourself you're checking all
those doing that no if you lived life
worrying about that it would happen
another way and then you'd be like i
should have done all this you know yeah
it happens the way it's supposed to
happen and the way you're doing it
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing yeah it to even get there i mean
jesus across this country flying
especially during a pandemic a flying
now sucks the fly now is terrible and i
don't think during this
the way the culture is now flying it's
so crazy it would have been so much
harder then i'm so fortunate that it was
during
a quarantine even though it had its own
restrictions because we could only go
one at a time which was so [ __ ]
infuriating so when's the last time you
saw your mom how long before she passed
um
i visited probably that last time
in november i think i was there in early
november
december she passed
friday the 13th no
[Laughter]
you come in the hospital wearing a jason
mask hey guys it's a machete
i got donuts like who is this [ __ ]
lunatic it's right there
[Laughter]
yeah we got some pretty men this is
terrible
friday 13th is definitely unlucky for
you there's no doubt about it
i tell you you're a 20 layer dip i swear
it just keeps coming it can't it just
can't be
it couldn't have been just a [ __ ]
sunday yeah
which is still a thing yeah
oh god
oh [ __ ]
two weeks before her birthday no
no
no
no the hits just keep on coming don't
forget
oh god [ __ ]
yeah um that's hard
and it
it was a choice that we had had to make
it wasn't like she died
we yeah yeah we should assign papers
it was a you know a medical a medically
induced
situation
where
um
or reduced you should say because she
was basically on support at that point
and
i was planning on coming home
but the time it would take for me to
come home to get there was too long and
also even just to fly i was like can we
just
keep her with us until i get home
that's that's what i wanted and you know
back to the conversation about
selfishness
is
that was the decision that was like the
hardest decision
because she had turned so bad in a few
hours we got another call being like
this is we have to make a decision on
what we're going to do with end of life
now because
there's no more we can do for her and
you're in california and i'm in
california um and you're getting calls
from your what system my sister yeah
and
i was like just let me get there
you know
and
the argument was we could do that
we could we could
stave off doing
what we're going to do to pull her off
of things and ease her into
death
or we can do it now now the problem with
waiting is
she could still go in the night and then
she's going to be alone
or we can kind of control it now
and have whoever we can have
be with her
be with her
and
and also
24 more hours on support's going to be
957 thousands
i love you
this is our saving this is how we save
you some money look we're gonna give you
a two for one do you have anybody else
who's dying
because if you want to bring them in we
can extend the medication this nurse
right here has two hands okay
so you get the call that your sister's
gonna go
my sister let her my step-dad and my
brother-in-law so they did let more for
this they did they do yeah that was the
special the covet specials if someone's
dying people can come see it like it's a
[ __ ] shamu show
they're like oh dude no no one needs
anybody around when they're [ __ ]
living
but let's bring a
whole
auditorium of people for the death
i get it but i i
i was furious it doesn't matter if you
get covered in this wing
you know what i'm saying
covets the least of your worries in this
wing over here where we got it [ __ ]
so
i mean not to be
funny for real do you facetime do
anything okay
do they offer it yeah cause it's coveted
time and that was big at the time my mom
a lot during this process okay good um
even when she wasn't necessarily
coherent i still would call and and the
you know the nurses were amazing and the
nurses who have all these
jobs to do we're also facetiming family
members which takes a lot because they
need their hands to do all the jobs that
they do their jobs are so [ __ ]
complicated
um but my sister facetimes me now i'm on
an ipad i'm not like on a phone
and it's
the mechanics of it are a little
complicated because you're inducing
morphine
and there's a time period so there's a
little there's some mechanics to
consider
um
and also an ipad and i'm an ipad to them
i'm an ipad i'm sure more but you know
my sister
like
is like holding the phone so i can talk
to my mom
and my mom is out of it you know she's
kind of doing that
the death gargle situation where you
know death is just kind of waiting in
the parking lot at that point
and at one point my sister goes you know
she's holding the ipad
me and she goes to her husband here take
this
to about the ipad my [ __ ] i'm not a
this
i realize you're there and there's a lot
to juggle but i can't be there i'm a
[ __ ] ipad
that's out in the parking lot revenge
that cigarette's
come on man we got three more to pick up
that is like fast
12 in the parking lot
that's what i see in my mind to an old
[ __ ] dodge yeah it's what's his name
it's it's paul walker driving
[Laughter]
come on man
that cigar i'm taking this one down to
the butt man hold on
[Laughter]
uh you're so sweet you're the best to be
able to joke about this [ __ ] with us i
was just thinking the same thing
my face hurts
um
and so my sister like hands me to her
husband
and he like
props me up and
and then the ipad falls
and i go guys
i go guys i can't see and then i
realized how weird that statement was
like i can't see my mom's death
like even just having to consider that
as a luxury
could you imagine being a child and
someone just comes up to you and says
you're gonna watch your mom's death on
something called an ipad you're like
what
what do you mean you either because
before you either were there or you
missed this you were there you missed it
yes
there's no [ __ ] in between no in
between no and it's in
that's such a good point because
i would imagine that adds a level of a
little psychological turmoil to a
child's development because they're
already blurring the lines of reality
with the ipad as it is in their
developmental mind and so you throw this
in it almost
on one hand
takes away the levity of
death and life
and on the other hand
it
it adds
this confusing
association and relationship with life
and death
um
but i felt that you know it
i missed both of my parents deaths
but we don't get to really experience
our own births well listen
i saw my father's and my grandmother was
it much it was too much
okay i would rather have missed them as
well
i would have rather got the call if i'm
being out of it like that eating popcorn
one i'm closing his eyes i'm giving her
[ __ ] cpr mouth-to-mouth you know what
i mean
i'm saying i would much rather [ __ ]
get that get the face time i'll i'll get
my tickets
oh my god that's a different trauma
that's a good point it's a solid point
appreciate the perspective check you're
welcome
i'd rather be put the ipad down i don't
want to see [ __ ] i've been the other way
somebody tip it over god damn it i'm
like can someone turn on a lightning put
a piece of tape on that goddamn i can't
see mom not breathing can someone turn
on a light
and did you watch your mom pass
um
yeah
so you were essentially i was present
that's a wild thing
it's really weird
that's a wild thing to comprehend
watching your parent pass is very
strange
a device
it's crazy it's so future so it felt
very futuristic and i was fortunate and
grateful that i even had that but
what are the some of the things you you
were able to talk to your mom about
while you were in she was in that
hospital um
we just
that's the thing about both my parents
my mom and i while she was in the
hospital would just
while she was coherent which is a very
hand like a handful of times small
amount of times where she was actually
able to have like an actual back and
forth conversation because she was
always plugged up and then after that
procedure she had she was intubated so
she can't talk and she was so [ __ ]
uncomfortable
um
we always would just say we love each
other we would hold hands and squeeze
each other's hands did you play music or
anything we played some music um you
know she loved fleetwood mac stevie
nicks was like one of her favorites
oh come on the greatest
um and music was definitely like a
a tool for communication
and just being there you know
with both of my parents
there weren't many stones unturned
there weren't many
regrets that i had with either of them
where if you know i'd only said this or
if i'd only said this we said everything
we squeezed the life
out of each other and we always
always always always said i love you
didn't matter if you're going to target
or if you're getting on a flight i love
that i believe in that
absolutely and to say it like you mean
it
and
both my mother and father
so
a lot more was unsaid then said with her
because so much had been said during
life that
being there was all the conversation
that either of us wanted or needed
obviously me being the eternal optimist
i'm trying to crack jokes and
and bring light and levity to the
situation and i think she knew you know
after she had that procedure
where she was intubated afterwards
she just was
trying to take it off
you know i think she fought so much in
her life as a as a woman and was you
know a union rep and fought for people
and did so much fighting
that when it came to fighting for her
own life
the will
power
is the turning point i think for a lot
of people and especially her
where you have a conversation with
yourself am i going to keep going or am
i going to stop
because i really do believe in your
mindset being able to overcome a lot of
your body's dysfunction
i mean there's a real
reality and truth to that
and not everybody has a dave goggins in
the last moments not everybody has the
ability and a lot of people just don't
want to anymore and i think for her
she was done
you know because what was gonna what her
life was gonna be we're talking about
quality of life beyond this wasn't
anything she'd want she'd have to be
intubated for so long
and i mean i know i wouldn't want to be
like that no no
just so people can come over and say hi
once a week yeah take pictures with me
and my machine right
right and i'm gonna find it and i'm
making you know what are we gonna start
a band with me and my neck tube oh man
the intubators
i was able
to in my own way
say goodbye to both of my parents and to
and for both of my parents to know that
i was okay and loved and
and appreciated them and
a lot of people don't get that
and that's their biggest [ __ ] regret
you know
um
i think
holding a grudge
and having that sort of
relationship with somebody in your life
and your family where something happened
and you're just not over it and
you let that be the thorn in between you
two really comes to bite you in the ass
in the end
i think a grudge does nothing for
anybody i think
working through whatever the hardest
part is is for you and not for them a
lot of people can't do that there's a
lot of terrible [ __ ] that happens that
this podcast is highlighted throughout
the years we know a lot of low light a
lot of [ __ ] low lights that aren't so
easy to just turn
a blind guy yeah you're right sometimes
it takes decades some people never do it
yep some people want to and then don't
get the chance to because life is so
[ __ ] fleeting like you said you get
one day you get a call and it's like
guess what
yeah
not everybody gets it i think about it a
lot too especially as i get older now
like
there's some a lot of my friends now are
dealing with elderly parents and what to
do with them you know do i put them in a
home because someone's losing their mind
or they're losing their health or
they're losing the ability to walk and
be mobile i never had to deal with that
yeah you know i mean look i would have
traded it all in but again that's
selfish now my father died very young 42
my grandma was 69 but
um
i'm watching these people deal with
these things and i think man
that's i would i also wouldn't want to
watch
no the superman no you know you think
your parents are the [ __ ] immortal
one yeah like they're always gonna be
here and then one day they're not you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah and you're if
there's this uh
untethered feeling
when both your parents are gone so let
me ask you what do you do i know i
with these podcasts we all do we keep
people alive stories alive and that's
what i've done but um there are other
ways i keep my dad my grandmom people
like that live in my life what are you
doing now
what sort of things do you do in your
day-to-day or your home do you
you know keep your parents alive and
around you have some photos some i do
i have some photos and keepsakes and i
actually have
both my parents taxidermied at the table
what i'm just trying to say it as a joke
are you but are you trying to tell me
they're in an urn at your table though
no their bodies are taxatory all right
you are just fine there's a woman who
did who did that
they found like her
it might be like can't do a sam tripoli
news story but there's a woman who had
her husband like taxidermied at the
table and i just saw that sits there
he's just there like
get the [ __ ] i did see uh
i did see it was a hip-hop club or
something in dc where these guys took
their dead friend because that's what he
wanted his last [ __ ] thing was like
take me to the club and they had his
dead ass that propped up
it's online standing up
dead as [ __ ] and they're all dancing
around them and having a good time
ordering drinks and [ __ ] i think it's a
weekend of bernie that's exactly what it
is hip-hop version
you know [ __ ] crazy at my
i have rings
that were my mom's
and yeah they're pretty um thank you
they
this one's your mom can i touch you yeah
both of them
and when she was alive we would always
joke that when she was dead i would
steal him off her fingers
and so i just laugh like when i look at
them i laugh and think about him while
she was technically still alive i ripped
him right off of her in the hospital
yeah
i had to crack a knuckle but you know
not even dead yet
heart monitor goes off i don't know what
happened
i walk out of the hospital like
bling bling
um
i keep them alive by talking to them
both
i
you know and
you know i'm a spiritual person and i'm
open to
the idea of what existence is
as we are now existentially and beyond i
i'm not
naive enough or
assuredly enough
to think i know what the [ __ ] goes on
beyond this physical life i don't even
know what goes on here
i was like i don't i don't know what
goes on like on a day-to-day basis i
question what this [ __ ] is and that's
what keeps you
such an interesting human being like the
one thing i know for certain is i know
nothing's not certain nothing nothing
and that keeps me grounded it also keeps
you open to learning yeah the idiot the
ignorant idiot that thinks he knows
everything
knows nothing you know nothing you can't
learn anymore if you knew if you knew
everything there'd be nothing left to
learn exactly and there's a erica badu
lyric that i love she says the man that
thinks he knows something knows he knows
nothing at all
and that's how i've lived and that's how
i live especially through grief it
really keeps an open space for learning
it keeps an open space for you to
for
whatever it is to be revealed to you so
you can
react
um and and experience it in
a calmer place but i have conversations
with them and i and
i definitely have like a jewelry thing
with my mom and i had a necklace from my
dad actually that he gave me when i was
16.
and i lost it when i was in greece this
past month
yeah like three days in i was filming
something for netflix and
the necklace was just gone i've had it
for 33 years
and um
it it really taught me a lot about
letting go
it's so crazy my daughter must have like
seven or eight necklaces already you
know and i i told her because she's very
precious about mm-hmm but i was too like
we all are about our things this watch
my dad i told her i've told her already
like listen
it's not about the things it's the
moments and the memories i'm telling you
if for whatever reason you ever lose
that necklace and i'm not around don't
[ __ ]
don't
melt down over that like it's a necklace
remember who got you the necklace i got
you and you know things like the
memories and the moments not that
[ __ ] thing because that thing
it's gonna go you don't know you're out
swimming in the waves boom there goes my
[ __ ] necklace what are you
supposed to do nothing you ain't finding
that [ __ ] in the ocean forget it it's
over
it's interesting like when we talk about
possessions like you either possess them
or they possess you yes and when it
comes to relationship to people
the possession is the moment what you're
trying to possess and the message that
you have that's it and they're already
in you yeah and i remind i have to
remind myself that's not something that
is just
this
ethereal idea i have to physically
in in like
actually remind myself of that every day
well look i know we have to get you out
of here yeah because my dog ate glass
yesterday my dog glass i'm the next
episode four
um please again plug and promote
everything you would like
well we unplugged my mom so
[Laughter]
can't plug that
wow
[Laughter]
man
um sharp tongue podcast
check out girl on patreon gyrl
and also the deuce on patreon with my
friend mike tully
and jessemay.com for tickets for my fall
shows
and um look out for my netflix yeah at
jessiemaypaluso on instagram and all
your dad is in my dms all your dads are
in her dna i'm not a homewrecker thank
you for real thank you i love you too
this is i know it wasn't easy but god
damn you make it funny
you make it you help me make it make me
so funny you give us a safe space for
all our darkness thank you for real um
as always ryan sickler and all social
media ryan
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]